do you let your kids have phones and be
on social media my daughter just will
like watch reals and stuff my wife she's
always trying to monitor what they're
watching because like even on the
YouTube kids app like they got all this
weird stuff that's like not kids stuff
my wife Sonia is the same she's like oh
like you got to keep an eye on it and
then you could just say like no more of
that and you can kind of curate The
Experience so my son's four um and my
daughter's about to be three so like my
son watches super book on YouTube all
the time YouTube kids app do they like
blippy yeah my my daughter does you ever
seen Gracie's Corner no oh dude that's
some fire